StStéphanie, Alec, Christian,
bobonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Cela bouge sur la scène
popolitique québécoise.
OnOn a le résultat ça va être la
cacampagne ennuyeuse. Pas du to.
C'C'est pas commencé que déjà ça
bobouillonne. Il y a de vieille,
dede vieux débats qui
reresurgissent. Alors, Madame S-
HiHilaire que l'on a vu hier qua
anannoncé son arrivée dans
ShSherbrooke qui va être les
cicirconscriptions à surveiller
cocontre Québec solidaire, je vs
fafais entendre Madame St-Hilai,
ququi parle du troisième lien
paparce qu'elle était plutôt
cocontre quand elle était
chchroniqueuse. Elle est plutôt
popour maintenant. Monsieur
LeLegault parle de ses
sosouverainistes qui vont arriv.
MoMonsieur Drainville demain. On
écécoute cela et on revient.
CACAROLINE ST-HILAIRE, candidat,
CACAQ, Sherbrooke
- - À l'époque, quand
jeje m'exprimais notemment
susur le troisième lien, il faut
sese rappeler, c'était loin d'êe
lele projet qu'on a aujourd'hui.
EtEt donc, autant
lele projet a évolué, je voudras
quque ma position a évolué
popour plusieurs raisons,
n notemment parce qu'il y a
unune offre de transport
enen commun qui est très
inintéressante, et que c'est
dedevenu un réseau structurant
popour l'ensemble de la région.
EtEt ça, je trouve que c'est
trtrès intéressant pour les gens
dede Québec, mais aussi pour
leles gens de Lévis. Alors, je s
trtrès, très, très bien
avavec le troisième lien.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT, premier
miministre du Québec
- - Non, je pense e pas que je s
prprétendre les avoir fait chanr
d'd'idée. Ce qui est important,
papar contre, c'est que, comme
lele disais François tantôt,
pependant 40 ans, on a été
didivisés entre souverainistes
pupuis fédéralistes.
NoNous, ce qu'on veut, c'est fae
avavancer la nation québécoise
àà l'intérieur du Canada.
DoDonc, on y croit, aller chercr
plplus de pouvoir pour défendre
nonotre langue, nos valeurs,
nonotre culture, on y croit.
PuPuis, c'est appuyé par beaucop
dede Québécois. Donc, je pense
quque les Québécois sont rendus
llà. Et oui, on est
unune coalition, mais en même
tetemps, on est une coalition
nanationaliste.
CoCoalition nationaliste. Donc n
a a parlé la semaine dernière, l
veveut élargir la tente encore
plplus. Stéphanie, coup sur coup
MaMadame St-Hilaire et Monsieur
DrDrainville et Monsieur Legault
didit : cela illustre un état de
fafait.
- - Oui c'est certain. Ce qui me
frfrappe d'abord, sur le premier
exextrait que vous avez fait
jojouer, Caroline St-Hilaire c't
inintéressant d'avoir comment ls
didiscours changent quand on
adadhère à la CAQ. Ça me fait
pepenser à celle qui s'est
prprésentée dans Marie-Victorin
ququi avait écrit et envers le
gogouvernement à propos du racie
sysystémique. C'est drôle quand
elelle s'est présentée, tout à
cocoup, sa position avait changé
auaussi un peu comme celle de
MaMadame St-Hilaire sur le
trtroisième lien, donc que oui
ququand on adhère au gouverneme,
onon adhère aussi opposition. Sr
lala question de la souverainet,
c'c'est sûr que Madame St-Hilai,
unune ancienne du Bloc, Monsieur
DrDrainville qui est le père dea
chcharte des valeurs, cela fait
dedeux ajouts qui vont plutôt ds
lele sens de la souveraineté. E-
cece que ça va peut-être laisser
cecertains électeurs avec ce
poportrait? Ça reste à voir. C't
ssûr que cela change. Est-ce que
lala CAQ va vraiment cacher de
fafaire la souveraineté? Je
papasserai pas honnêtement. C'et
unun projet qui n'a pas de chane
dede se concrétiser. C'est la
dedernière des priorités des
jejeunes en ce moment. Donc je
crcrois pas que ce soit une
crcrainte justifiéiée par
- - Comme disait Monsieur Bouchd
dadans une entrevue qui a fait
jajaser qu'il m'a donné vendred,
MoMonsieur Legault est réaliste.
IlIl est lié la carte actuelle t
nene voit pas arriver absolument
papas de référendum ou de débat
llà-dessus. À la clé, c'est un
pupuissant message qu'il envoie.
- - Dans un souci d'équilibre pr
gagarder sa coalition
inintacte il faudrait peut-être
ququ'il annonce quelquefois une
cacandidature fédéraliste. Ça
feferait peut-être pas de tort.
PePeut-être que Sonia Lebel se
sesentirait moins seule.
C'C'est un jeu d'équilibre auss.
SoSouvenez-vous, quand la a été
lalancé, on allait chercher les
dédéputés qui faisaient la Suan
CACAQ.
FrFrançois Legault était à côtén
didisant que ce n'est pas notre
prpriorité. Est-ce que c'est un
raramassis de toutes sortes de
momonde ce parti? Est-ce que ily
a a une cohérence idéologique?
CeCela avait vraiment fait mal à
lala cAQ. Les témoins enracinés.
N'N'empêche, ce petit
ququestionnement sur Ouest on sn
vava à long terme aventureux
susurgir si on ne peut pas avoir
d'd'autres candidatures en
éqéquilibre. Je pense pas qu'ily
a a danger dans la demeure
acactuellement mais il faudra
ququ'elle y pense éventuellement
s's'il veut s'assurer que le mot
cocoalition encore tout son sen.
CÇa reste de bonnes candidatures
CaCaroline St-Hilaire et Bernard
DrDrainville peuvent bien
s's'exprimer. Ils sont de bon
cocommunicateur. Les deux sont
miministres à tout à fait. Si on
veveut élargir la capacité du
gogouvernement à s'élargir,
çaça prend des figures pour les
reremplacer. On vient de trouver
dedeux
= = Christian?
- - C'est dans l'esprit de la C.
MoMonsieur Legault était lui-mêe
sosouverainiste je pense plus qe
c'c'est si important que cela.
LeLes souverainiste ne sont plus
cece qu'elles étaient. Il en
chchoisit le pouvoir. C'est cla.
C'C'est le pouvoir qui les
inintéresse. Le PQ représente ps
lele voir. Il faut les juger sur
leleur candidature et jusqu'à ql
popoint c'est intéressant, il ft
lalaisser la chance au coureur.
J'J'ai beaucoup de respect. Je
susuis pas convaincu entre autrs
popour Bernard Drainville. Parce
quque Bernard Drainville est trs
coconnu. Cela fait vieux.
IlIl a déjà été journaliste.
OnOn dit ce qu'on pense. Ma
prpremière réaction, je me suis
didit : c'est un journaliste. Ia
fafait de la politique. Ça n'a s
étété transcendant. Ce n'était s
jujuste journaliste mais un
ananimateur de radio tous les
jojours à Montréal.
IlIl est extrêmement connu et
prprésent. Ce n'est pas nouveau.
JeJe suis pas sûr que l'on a un
nanationalisme québécois ferme
avavec Bernard Drainville.
- - Je reviens...
- - on va juger. L'importance de
sasavoir si c'était des anges
sosouverainistes est-ce que ce
sesera performant?
- - Je reviens sur ce que vous
avavez dit Christian et je refas
unun tour de table. Vous dîtes e
c'c'est pas très important. On
n'n'est plus là à savoir si on t
sosouverainiste ou pas. Si on pe
lala question à Monsieur
DrDrainville : je suis
sosouverainiste sûrement. C'estn
rrêve comme Monsieur Bouchard.
MaMais je crois que c'est
ababsolument irréaliste de pensr
ququ'on peut proposer aux
QuQuébécois une démarche incarne
ababsolument vers la souveraine.
LeLes deux peuvent aller de pai.
AvAvec des collègues fédéralists
auau conseil des ministres si la
dédémarche n'est pas là, ça ne
chchange rien à court terme.
- - En effet. Je pense pas que e
tete l'accord avec Stétéphanie.e
pepense pas que personne s'atted
àà ce que François Legault ne
fafasse référendum demain matin.
CeCe n'est pas dans ses cartonst
sasa coalition éclaterait. On pt
ququand même se poser la questin
susur le long terme. Qu'est-ce
ququ'on veut avoir comme
didiscussions avec Ottawa dans a
féfédération? Est-ce qu'on va
prprendre les ministres qui
sysystématiquement s'opposent au
ouou des solutions à proposer. s
dedeux approches sont différents
enentre la confrontation et
trtrouver des solutions dans le
toton et la manière de s'y
prprendre. Ça va être intéressat
dede voir dans la coalition,
QuQuébec est-ce que le ton plus
babatailleur de Bernard Drainvie
ququi est naturellement plus
babatailleur, mais François
LeLegault l
,e,est aussi.
- - C'est intéressant.
- - Ça peut être intéressant sur
lala fibre identitaire pour
rereprendre le mot à la mode dea
cocollection avenir Québec
- - Comment on définit les
prproblèmes devant nous? Soit de
fafaçon que l'on prend la
coconcentration où il peut y avr
dedes ententes.
- - C'est qu'il y a des gens qui
sosont dans la souveraineté.
PaPar rapport à la loi 21 et la
loloi sur le français. Parce que
c'c'est comme si sont pas capabs
d'd'imaginer un Québec autre que
sosouverains. Le Québec va peut-
êêtre être souverain momentané.
MaMais il me semble que ça va
rerevenir à un moment où on ne y
atattendra pas. Les suppositions
d'd'aujourd'hui je trouve cela
sasans intérêt.
LeLe souverainiste, c'est la foe
dede François Legault parce que
leles Québécois ne sont pas là.
- - En même temps, il y a des gs
quque l'on peut plus difficilemt
didire quand on a été chef du
paparti québécois.
LaLa soeur de René-Lévesque a éé
trtrès choquée par les propos qe
MoMonsieur Bouchard a tenus sur
cecette antenne et d'autres, mas
esessentiellement dans cette
lolongue entrevue où il a été ts
dudur envers les Parti québécoi.
IlIl a dit : il y en aura un
auautre. Ce n'est pas le véhicue
imimportance à l'idée et qu'elle
rereste vivante. Il a dit qu'il
fafaut être honnête que j'ai un
grgrand respect pour les gens qi
mimilitaient dans ce parti. Mais
dede proposer un référendum, ce
n'n'est pas réaliste. Monsieur
LéLévesque avait cette qualité
d'd'être réaliste. Ce que n'a ps
llâché factuellement. Bref, la
sosoeur de René-Lévesque 93 en n
fufurie. Voici un extrait.
ToTour de table. Stéphanie,
MoMonsieur Bouchard a dit ce
ququ'elle pensait.
MaMais pour les PQ, cela ajoute
auau chemin de croix.
- - C'est sur quel chemin de
crcroix, il est pénible en ce
momoment pour les PQ. Il va peu-
êêtre se retrouver à l'issue du
prprojet scrutait avec un seul
dédéputé. Monsieur Bérubé dans n
MaMatapédia. Ce que le sondage
didise c'est pas glorieux. Et
pupuis, Monsieur Bouchard et je
pepense qu'elle a été réaliste.
EsEst-ce que c'était le bon momt
ququand on célèbre la mémoire de
ReRené-Lévesque de dire des chos
tetelles qu'elles sont? Peut-ête
quque c'était difficile à
enentendre. En même temps, on pt
papas cacher la vérité non plus.
EtEt je pense qu'effectivement,e
ququi soulignait aussi, de dire:
évéventuellement ça va prendre e
opopposition à Québec parce quee
ququ'on voit en ce moment, la
cocoalition avenir Québec aura
tetellement de députés et peut-
êêtre 80 % des députés malgré le
fafait qu'elle pourrait avoir
seseulement 40 % des intentionse
vovote,
ququi va lui tenir tête? C'est
l'l'Parti libéral n'est plus que
l'l'ombre de lui-même et il est
paparti québécois est rayé de la
cacarte. C'est quand même
imimportant dans une démocratie
d'd'avoir une opposition forte t
àà l'heure actuelle, on voit
ququ'effectivement, une option
susuffisamment solide pour tenir
ttête à un parti au gouvernemen,
onon voit pas trop ça va venir :
- - Parce que même s'il peut avr
dede la sympathie pour Monsieur
LeLegault, Monsieur Bouchard di:
leles libéraux doivent se relevr
paparce que c'est malsain.
- - D'abord, le saint Bouchard a
papas été tendre envers les Pari
ququébécois qui lui-même n'a pas
étété tendre envers Lucien
BoBouchard. Il faut se rappeler
ququ'elle s'est Bouchard pendant
dede nombreux congrès lorsque cs
phphotos apparaissaient les
mimilitants U et Lucien Bouchar.
C'C'est le seul chef du parti
ququébécois qui avait ce
trtraitement. Je me souviens...
ilil y a quand même toujours eu
unune tension entre les Parti
ququébécois et Lucien Bouchard.l
ététait bien présent. En même
tetemps, Stéphanie a raison. C't
trtrès réaliste de le dire et me
s's'il n'est pas naturel Parti
québécois Lucien Bouchard,
JaJacques Parizeau n'était havé
didit que les Parti québécois
ététaient des ruines. On accusea
jajamais Jacques Parizeau n'est
papas à être un fier partisan du
PQPQ. Il a été là depuis ses
dédébuts. Il y a là-dedans un
coconstat que certainement matie
àà mettre en collègue Alice
LéLévêque et d'autres militants.
MaMais la réalité ressemble quad
mmême à cela. Je vais juste te
teterminer en disant : Lucien
BoBouchard est porte-parole et
prprésident d'honneur du son
ananniversaire de René-Lévesquet
nonon pas du Parti québécois.
C'C'est René-Lévesque qui est la
fifigure que Lucien Bouchard enr
ququi a lui-même été au Parti
lilibéral du Québec.
DoDonc, ce n'est pas à Lucien
BoBouchard de faire l'apologie u
PQPQ. Ce n'est pas ce qu'elle dt
fafaire.
- - Et les Parti québécois n'a s
étété tendre avec René-Lévesque
nonon plus. On se refera pas
totoutes les sommes en question?
- - Je comprends très bien Madae
LéLévêque elle a raison. J'espèe
avavoir une vivacité d'esprit à3
anans. Incroyable. Parce que
c'c'était très déplacé.
IlIl a oublié qui il était. C'et
l'l'ancien chef du Parti
ququébécois. Et c'est un ancien
prpremier ministre péquiste.
CaCampagne électorale qui s'en
vivient. Ou les PQ jouent sa pe.
OnOn peut penser tout cela, on
pepeut penser que les PQ est fi.
MaMais Lucien Bouchard, ce n'étt
papas et Osala. Il est déprécié
leles parties qu'il a dirigées
jujuste avant un combat élector.
JeJe suis tombé en bas de ma
chchaise quand j'écoutais cela
paparce que cela a attiré mon
atattention. Ils chantent leles
lolouanges Parti libéral. L'idie
cece n'est pas de savoir s'il
avavait raison ou pas. C'était e
didiscussion de bon niveau entre
vovous et lui je trouve que
c'c'était pas à lui de tirer sur
leles Parti québécois avant de
cacampagne électorale. Madame
LéLévêque, je dis pas ça par
gegentillesse, quand elle rappee
quque c'est bien beau mais le Bc
ququébécois, on a tous enterrésn
momoment donné. Où en est-on? Ia
reressuscité pour le parti
coconservateur à Ottawa lorsque
s's'est retrouvé avec deux
dédéputés, juste en train de die
quque les PQ va performer
mamagiquement, mais c'est pas
enencore fait.
- - En fait, vous dîtes que
c'c'était déplacé de le dire pae
quque qu'elle pense, on peut pas
lele reprocher...
mamais de dire que de promettren
réréférendum c'est réaliste, et
quque Lévêque...
- - je suis pas d'accord. Au
cocontraire parce que tout le
momonde sait que les Parti
ququébécois n'a pas une chance
d'd'avoir le pouvoir. De promete
unun référendum il faut voir un
sesens programmatique. C'est
sisimplement que rappeler que ln
esest souverainiste
cocomparativement aux autreses.
- - C'est assumé pendant
exexactement. Le PQ prendra pase
popouvoir.
- - Je trouve que c'était déplaé
etet que la soeur de René-Lévese
àà 93 ans, on nous dit quand ona
9090 ans, c'est l'âge grandiose
dédésormais.
- - L'âge n'a rien à voir. Tant
mimieux.
- - Quand j'ai vu la nouvelle, e
meme suis dit à la vieille
MaMadame...
- - c'était une discussion
inintelligente. C'était grâce à
lului.
- - C'est l'ancien chef du Parti
ququébécois. Certains
cocommentateurs politiques.
- - Mais j'ai posé la question t
ilil a répondu. Après un temps
d'd'année, Monsieur Parizeau l'a
fafait, tout l'on fait. Lisée ft
çaça tous les jours au bord de a
popolitique.
- - Mais il y a une élection das
trtrois mois.
- - Combien il reste de temps?
ReRegardant le tableau vite. Ona
enen parler demain. La carte de
memembre vendue pour la directin
dudu parti conservateur. Monsier
PoPoilièvre, je vais prendre une
phphrase de Jean-François Lisée:
leles parties conservateur a ene
d'd'avoir sa période Poilièvre.
C'C'est ce qu'elle avait dit sue
PKPKP6
- - il faut qu'ils réussissent à
momobiliser ses membres prendre
leles prochains mois. Ça va être
dede très longs mois.
CÇa va être intéressant. Ce n'et
papas fini quand même.
- - On va en reparler. Est-ce qe
MoMonsieur Charest..